so why are blue collar workers burning
their barn jackets
you may have seen videos circulating
over social media of anti-vax carhartt
customers defacing and burning their
clothing
[Music]
while code vaccinations have become a
tinderbox in u.s politics with those on
the right advocating against government
and corporate sponsored vaccine mandates
thank you for calling carver customer
service
what's next is oakley sunglasses is
going to make their employees get the
jab is this yeti coolers gonna make me
get the jab i don't think so so what
does this have to do with carhartt well
it's politics being played out in
fashion over here
we still have the mandate so if you're
gonna work for us
you're gonna get the thing carhartt made
its name supplying laborers and farm
workers but it has also long been
claimed by the fashion industry where
he's established a distinct work in
progress design line appealing to a
completely different demographic which
might go some way to explaining why
carhartt doesn't seem so worried about
alienating the jacket burners
[Music]